[Music]
[Applause]
the agent for Freddie Freeman strongly
denied a tweet from Fox sports radio
host Doug Gottlieb that he withheld from
Freddie Freeman the Braves final
contract offer that agent is Casey close
who's been around a long time and said
that he is considering legal action over
that report he called Doug's tweet uh
Reckless said there's no truth whatever
whatsoever to what Doug Gottlieb
recklessly tweeted and I would testify
that under oath we are currently
evaluating all legal options in this
matter what doug tweeted yesterday that
uh
the the agent never told Freddie Freeman
about the Braves final offer that's why
Freeman fired him he found out in
Atlanta this weekend it uh isn't that
rare to have that happen in baseball but
it happened and uh he followed by that
by saying uh Casey close knew Freddie
would have taken the Atlanta deal let's
bring in the uh great baseball writer
Tom berducci Sports Illustrated kind
enough to join us Tom thanks for joining
us let's go back to the World Series it
felt like it's a foregone conclusion
that Freddie Freeman was going to leave
the Braves or certainly it was talked
about a lot what do you remember about
that covering the World Series
yeah I think all of us in the media kind
of took it for granted that Freddy was
just a brave for life right team drafted
him at a high school basically grew up
there
um but you know I started to hear from
other people Freddie was telling people
that hey you know if the Braves don't
treat me right if they kind of drag
their feet on this I wouldn't mind going
back to Southern California he's from
Orange County obviously and that had an
attraction to him it wasn't his goal I
mean he he made a plane he wanted to
remain a brave for life and the brave
said they wanted to keep him so based on
what the motivations were at least
publicly Dan we all thought this was a
marriage just waiting to happen to get
it locked up but it kind of reminds me
of the Albert Poole situation right the
Cardinals win the World Series we all
think Albert's going back to St Louis
and St Louis made an offer that really
he was easy for him to decline based on
what the market was and uh and Albert
left
but I wonder
do you think the Braves wanted Freddie
Freeman back is there is there maybe
like the Cardinals I think were thrilled
that Albert Pujols hey we tried we
couldn't keep you you went to the angels
you got paid they got the 10 best years
could this be similar that the Braves
said hey thank you Freddie
you take that offer you can't turn that
down
I think it might have gotten to that
point then I don't think they started
that way I do believe that they wanted
Freddie Freeman there and don't forget
we had the lockout let's put everything
on hold now when you've got a franchise
player like that it shouldn't get to the
situation where it's on hold through the
lockout that should have been done
before the lockout it wasn't but I do
believe the Braves initial plan was yeah
we want to keep Freddie Freeman here it
must be a way to do it but on the other
side of the lockout remember everything
now is under fast forward right it's not
business as usual opening day is just a
three weeks away you gotta ramp up and
figure out what your roster is who's
going where there was a little bit you
know planned negotiations under a gun at
that point again shouldn't have got
there but it did so now everything is
sped up and I do think at that point the
Braves started to consider what if we
can't resign this guy we've got to Pivot
now and obviously Matt Olson was a great
way to Pivot but I I don't think that's
how they started yeah probably didn't
but they probably got to the point where
they said look you're gonna make they're
going to offer you more money than we
can offer you and then you start to I
think that preemptive strike with
getting Olson in and then maybe Freddie
Freeman says wait a minute here what
just happened and I don't know like you
know why does he fire his agent why is
he fire Casey close
well I mean he said in a tweet I'm not
sure he get knowledge Freddie put out a
statement that um he didn't say he fired
him he's basically said it's on hold
right now and he's working through some
issues based on what he heard over the
weekend in Atlanta I'm sure he heard
from Braves people probably a different
story than what his version was or what
he understood it to be and the truth is
probably somewhere in the middle but
he's got to sort this thing through but
yeah I think it's hard of a heart for
anyone to be a brave and I think he was
blindsided when the Braves pivoted to
medals yeah and the Braves are listen
they're a smart organization as every
team is these days and realize we can
get a guy who's younger cheaper we're
buying the best years of metals and well
let's face it with Freddie you're buying
his decline in his 30s from a purely
analytical business point of view it was
easy for them to Pivot at that point
because they had a good option right
there and not a bonus the kid's from
Atlanta Olsen uh so that would help
people get over kind of the shock really
of losing Freddie but what do you think
happened this weekend where
you know I was told that Freddie was
aware of this in April but didn't want
to make a big deal out of it and then
the wave of emotion when he went back to
Atlanta it's one thing to get that that
you know response welcome home
but do you think somebody
throw out a name from the front office
pulled him aside just say hey just so
you know we did want to keep you
I could have been that it could have
been a player it could have been a staff
member or could a lot of people who
maybe was getting stories second hand
but I do think being back in Atlanta and
let's face it everybody was revisiting
why is it Freddy in a Brave's uniform so
a lot of info or semi info was churning
at that point and I'm sure Freddie heard
about it so yeah I think this had a lot
to do with it like he probably heard
something that he had not heard before
and let's face it the Braves want a
relationship with Freddie Freeman going
forward right you know he's not going to
finish his career as a brave but when
he's done he's still going to be thought
of as you know the world champion with
the Braves and an MVP with the Braves uh
probably go in the Hall of Fame as a
brave all those things are important
right so that relationship doesn't need
mending and I think Freddie and his
heart felt it emotional as you said over
the weekend very emotional so the easy
way out is blame it on the agent right
and we don't I don't think we really
know what actually happened what the
final Figures were but I've seen this
happen a lot before where where where
you want them in a relationship the
agent is the easy one to blame you don't
need a relationship or at least an
emotional one going forward where I
think Freddie wants to repair it with
the Braves and the Braves want to repair
it with Freddie
do you think Casey close uh goes after
Doug Gottlieb and Susan
I don't know about legal I mean people
say that we'll see I mean he you know
obviously based on the the words he
chose he's extremely angry listen
Casey's been doing this for a long time
this is not someone who just woke up and
it was an agent last week and was in
over his head he's got a sterling
reputation of the business he's been
doing it I think at least 30 years and
there's never been an instance that I
can remember where he went it's called
going rogue on a player where you
actually it's unbelievable to think
about this could happen where any agent
would have an offer from a team and the
team where the player wanted to play and
didn't tell him about it and again Dan
we're not in a situation where you could
slow play things things were moving very
quickly there wasn't time to slow play
things it's hard to believe that
scenario happened maybe it did we don't
know I think we need and I think we will
hear more from Casey close because we
haven't heard and I think it's time
somebody does and probably Casey
um to really Define what went down I'm
talking about revealing some of the
offers or at least the parameters of it
so that people have a better idea
especially Freddie has a better idea of
what happened yeah I wonder if there's
paperwork emails things like well they
keep notes Dad yeah I mean I don't know
about emails but they definitely keep
notes and figures at every agent every
Club has a written account of all the
talks that go on
you know he homered last night Freddie
Freeman um and then now and he's batting
over 300 the hometown crowd gets to
cheer him or welcome him or whatever
they do starting tonight but uh how do
you think this is going over with the
Dodgers the locker room itself because
Clayton Kershaw kind of hinted at uh hey
uh you know you're with us now I saw
that that was interesting right he said
I hope we're not second fiddle I mean
you did sign a six-year deal there you
are a Dodger as you said he's hitting
well I just think last weekend was just
so emotional for him to be back in
Atlanta
um you know there's still not closure to
what happened in Atlanta and Freddie
Freeman so I think he still has to work
through that but I think the feeling of
you know having an attachment to the
Braves will not be as strong as it was
last weekend just because physically he
was in Atlanta and hearing some things
but I I did catch that that uh quote
from Clayton Kershaw it was really
pretty telling and I think the players
have to say in the Dodger Clubhouse hey
man you're wearing a Dodger uniform now
let's get over this
if I gave Freddie Freeman a mulligan
what do you think he'd do
I think he'd be wearing a Braves uni
right now and it's again I say that
because you saw the emotions over the
weekend that wasn't somebody who had
turned a page or that closer a closure
this was someone who had real strong
attachments to that organization and
listen it's pretty cool for him to be
playing in La you know he's got his wife
his kids his dad are up in the suite
watching him every day he's gonna I
think apartment in Studio City 10
minutes in the ballpark it's not a bad
place to play and live right playing for
the Dodgers in L.A so I think over time
he's over it but
um Freddy's an emotional guy and it
wasn't just over the weekend that you
saw that Dan so that attachment is real
and and I think if you had a do-over for
the right money of course that's always
the deciding factor I think he would be
a brave I didn't cry like that at my
dad's funeral
well I mean I thought you know a one-off
yeah he's in that first press conference
I thought okay I get it it's really
reality is hitting him but reality kept
hitting him all day long all night long
it was weird but that's Freddy you gotta
love him for that because he doesn't try
to hide anything everything's real with
Freddy Before I Let You Go uh I know Rob
Manford the commissioner did an
interview with ESPN talks about robot
umpires by 2024 and also expansion is
this inevitable that uh we're gonna have
the automated Strike Zone and if we do
have expansion where are we going uh
first of all you have to resolve Oakland
and Tampa Bay they're ballpark issues
before we expand you've got options in
Nashville or Montreal Las Vegas those
are probably the top three for me and I
think those two teams they don't solve
their issues locally they wind up
filling two of those three spots okay
the owners do want to get to 32. we're a
long way off because I I think the
Oakland and Tampa Bay needs to be
resolved Robo Strike Zone not Robo Ops
Robo Strike Zone I think is definitely
happening
but I'm starting to think they really
like this challenge system that's in
place in the minor leagues they use it
as a hybrid then I don't know if you
heard about this it's sort of like
Hawkeye and tennis and you're watching
Wimbledon it's great right there's a
line called the guy said that was out
everybody looks at it in three seconds
you realize whether the ball's in or not
the crowd gets into it the visuals of it
are great you can do the same thing and
they are doing that with baseball so the
batter gets punched out on a pitch
that's a foot outside he says well I
want to challenge that it pops up on the
screen you can see it's a ball redo not
redo the pitch now it's a ball I like
that system rather than going full on
Robo on because I'm telling you if you
want that system it's going to cause a
lot of problems you know watching the
game when the counts 3-0 is the strike
zone the same as when it's on two no of
course not
umpires you know they're Arbiters of the
game they move the game along that
breaking ball is 12-6 that catches a
robo Strike Zone and it's not a strike
as we stand here today that's going to
create huge problems so I kind of like
this challenge system I'm coming around
to that where you do have the strike
zone to get the right biggest to get the
biggest calls right right maybe it's not
important to get a hundred percent right
every Ticky tack calling a seven to
nothing game on a 3-0 count
but that call that changes the game and
you watch games Dan you realize that you
know you realize some counts actually
change the outcome again get those ones
right and I'm telling you in the minor
leagues it happens in three or four
seconds it doesn't slow the game down
I'm starting to think that's the way
forward the technology is there
um and so far the reviews have been good
for the players in the minor leagues I
know you're busy thank you again for
joining us Tom you got mad at any time
it's Tom verducci Sports Illustrated
baseball senior writer